heute bleibt die Küche kalt ich habe mal
richtig Lust mir was zu bestellen aber
ich bin irgendwie ein bisschen
uninspiriert ich glaube ich lasse mir
heute mal was empfehlen und zwar von
drei verschiedenen Restaurants und wir
gucken erstmal bei welchen dafür gehe
ich ganz klassisch in meine liefer App
dann rufe ich da einfach an und sag hey
was könnt ihr mir eigentlich empfehlen
was ist für euch der Klassiker den ich
unbedingt essen sollte ich liebe es neue
Methoden auszuprobieren um neue Dinge
kennenzulernen und wir gehen einfach mal
hier in meiner liefer-app der Wahl auf
Restaurants ja ich will irgendwie mir
erstmal einen Überblick verschaffen food
Brother natürlich auch geil Shirley
submarine Sandwiches 9,6 natürlich auch
irre dann rufen wir da mal an ja du mir
max kurze frage ich wollte gerade bei
euch bestellen aber ich kann mich nicht
so wirklich entscheiden deshalb wollte
ich einfach nach eurer Empfehlung fragen
was muss man bei euch gegessen haben
Spanier zum Klassiker eigentlich der
schon sehr lecker ist okay dann bestelle
ich den Dankeschön gucken wir also was
der Spanier ist der Spanier mit
gekochtem Schinken pikanter Salami und
Gouda klingt nicht schlecht Weizen oder
Vollkornbrot machen wir mal Vollkornbrot
das sieht schon irgendwie geil aus sieht
halt so richtig so rustikal aus
irgendwie ne damit es auch mal siehst
Eric okay so ne schon weniger Subway als
Subway aber wahrscheinlich dafür auch
homemade und so Eisbergsalat Tomaten
Zwiebel dass ich mal weg kommt bestellen
wir also und such uns noch zwei weitere
Restaurants raus nächster Spot einer von
dem ich schon ganz viel gehört habe hier
in Köln und zwar razzo wiegen Pizza war
da gehe ich auch mal drauf suche ich mir
auch hier mal die Nummer raus ich weiß
es gibt viele Leute die nehmen nicht so
gerne den Hörer in die Hand und so aber
das ist so eine geile Methode um
herauszufinden was wirklich gut ist ja
hi Max hier ich habe eine kurze Frage
ich habe noch nie bei euch bestellt und
kann mich nicht so wirklich entscheiden
was ist bei euch so ein Klassiker was
wom it macht man nichts falsch was ist
eine Empfehlung
Klassiker eine Peperoni Salami wobei ich
hier dann tatsächlich spicy Meatballs
empfehlen würde spicy Meatballs
interessiert mich bei einem veganen Spot
deshalb würde ich sagen spicy Meatballs
mit Chiliöl okay 14,50 vegane Pizza wir
bestellen letzter Spot pokemacay mit
10,0 habe ich noch nie gesehen bei der
liefer App das heißt eigentlich müsste
alles gut sein
ja hallo hier Max ich habe eine kurze
Frage ich wollte gerade bei euch
bestellen und ich kann mich nicht
entscheiden habt ihr eine Empfehlung was
man bestellen sollte
Schule ist immer gut oder die Kim
schicken okay spicy Tuna klingt super ja
dann bestelle ich die vielen lieben Dank
geil
mit gelbflossen Thunfisch Sesam Chili
Wasabi Creme Frühlingszwiebeln Gari
Ingwer gurken-alapeño Kirschtomaten Nori
Algen Sesam und Chemie letzte Bestellung
geht jetzt in diesem Moment raus wie
lange hat das jetzt gedauert 10 Minuten
12 Minuten das kriegst du nicht mal im
Restaurant so schnell du wir hätten auch
darüber gehen können da essen gehen
holen das wäre hätte länger gedauert
geisteskrank also ist wirklich krank das
hätte echt länger gedauert das sieht
schon mal sehr sehr sexy aus und ich sag
mal so das tut so einer Pizza natürlich
gut wenn Sie möglichst kurz in diesem
Karton ist WoW und so sieht sie auch aus
wunderschöne tigerung entlang des Randes
wir haben hier ja das wird
wahrscheinlich Mozzarella Ersatz sein
Veganer dann Meatballs bisschen Oregano
oben drauf wunderschöne Farben vor allem
auch drei verschiedene Arten Paprika
allein die Paprika kostet wahrscheinlich
15 € und nicht nur Pizza sondern auch
Dip sieht aus wie eine Aioli kriegt auch
wieder ja juli und Pizza Brötchen
wahrscheinlich Pizzabrötchen Pizza wobei
das kenne ich aber das kriegen
okay dann schneiden wir rein das sieht
verdammt gut aus Messer ist da wir
schneiden einmal die Pizza an der Rand
ist nicht super crispy oder irgendwas
aber ich meine es lieferpizza vegan 15
Minuten Lieferzeit wir probieren
schön scharf ja
die schmeckt frisch die Tomatensoße ist
so richtig kräftig ne Tomate kann ja so
ein bisschen Salz rein so richtig so
schön fleischig schmecken tut sie die
miet Boys haben den Biss von Meatballs
als Fleischesser erkennt man einen
kleinen Unterschied aber diese Pizza ist
sexy also die ist wirklich sehr sehr
sehr sehr krass wir haben auch hier so
keine Jalapenos drauf die auch so
Schärfe mitbringen
jeder ist ja offiziell eigentlich auch
nicht egal juli ist eine Knoblauch Mario
richtig 100 % Geschmacks intensiv in so
eine Pizza gibt bin ich gerne vegan
fühlt sich sehr sehr gut an auf jeden
Fall
Bro ich finde die krasser als eine
einfache Tonne mit Zwiebeln ja weil die
auch eine geile Kreation ist einfach ja
ist eine richtig geile Kreation auch die
Paprika Note da drin ist geil spicy
meatball passt auch 100% geil getroffen
mein Geschmack 100% getroffen mit der
Empfehlung absoluter win die erste
Bestellung
ratso Pizza Kuss die zweite Bestellung
ist da das dürfte unser submarine
Sandwich sein wir haben auf jeden Fall
eine riesen Tüte das sieht aus als hätte
man irgendwie beim Bäcker ein Brot
verkauft zwei kleine milchschokoladen
dazu es hat zumindest eine Erwähnung
verdient gucken wir mal rein der Spanier
der ist es alter Schwede was 8,90 € für
diesen Apparat von einem Sandwich Subway
mehr oder weniger finde ich schon auf
jeden Fall verfärbt gerade wenn das so
selbst gebackenes Brot ist es sieht
einfach wirklich aus wie so ein schönes
belegtes ne so schönes belegtes Brötchen
ich finde aber auch sowas kann ich nicht
ganz reinziehen alleine es ist schon
hart nee
so Bungee
mal rein
du weißt ja Eric ich mag keinen
Aufschnitt ich habe bleibende Schäden
bekommen von meiner Schulzeit in der ich
irgendwie butterbrotsdosen mitbekommen
habe mit irgendwelchem Aufschnitt die in
meiner Schultasche hab reifen lassen und
mich dann selbst übelst davor geekelt
das habe ich mag bis heute keinen
Aufschnitt ich mag wirklich alles wenn
du es mir verkaufst als Geräusch hatte
Salami Milano dann okay so Salami aus
dem Supermarkt mag ich nicht ich finde
das wirklich hier drin gar nicht so ne
also das ist schon so ein geiles
fertiges Produkt also ein geiles rundes
Produkt weil fertig ist dann glaube ich
wenig wie ist das Brot von der
Konsistenz her im Vergleich zum sub oder
zu dem was wir selbst gemacht haben
vielleicht auch ja schon sehr geil ich
glaube ich weiß nicht ob das so eine
Legend ist aber in irgendwelchen Ländern
muss Subway glaube ich sein Brot als
Kuchen kennzeichnen weil es zu viel
Zucker hat das hier ist auf jeden Fall
ein echtes ehrliches Brot trotzdem schön
fluffy und es schmeckt richtig gut wenn
man gerade auch sowas Lust hat dann ist
das eine echte 10 von 10 und von der
Masse von dem will ich von dem von der
Größe her das wären bestimmt vier
belegte Brötchen
und wenn man jetzt wirklich mal die
Rechnung machen möchte ein belegtes
Brötchen kostet heutzutage auch 3,20 €.
bist du sogar günstiger mit schmeckt
richtig gut wirklich last but not least
die Bestellung von Pokémon Kai ich habe
ein bisschen nachgeforscht in der
Zwischenzeit und scheinbar steht das in
irgendeinem Zusammenhang mit dem
Excelsior ernsthotel in Köln fünf Sterne
sehr stabiles Hotel am Dom das erklärt
warum das vielleicht eine gewisse
Qualität mit sich bringt und es sieht
auch echt gut aus wohlgemerkt das ist
eine große Portion für
19,90 €. das ist wirklich teuer bei der
guten Bewertung kann ich mir eigentlich
nur vorstellen dass es krass ist es muss
auch krass schmecken finde ich ein
Kumpel von mir Grüße gehen raus an jenno
schwärmt auch immer davon ich bin noch
nie in den Genuss gekommen wir gucken
einmal wir haben hier sesamen schwarzen
und weißen Sesam dann eben den Tuner der
spicy ist wahrscheinlich durch diese
orange Pulver was über ist panori Chips
die auch schön trocken geblieben sind
bisschen Schnittlauch oh ordentlich Soße
Reis sieht gut aus
die Schärfe ist richtig geil hatte ich
gerade Ingwer auf dem Löffel oder ist
der Ingwer irgendwie so eingearbeitet in
die Bowl Ingwer aber auf jeden Fall mit
in der Bowl drinne hier habe ich zum
Beispiel keinen drauf weil ich habe so
diesen geilen Geschmack vom Sushi Ingwer
im Mund wasabi ist auch in dieser Mayo
Soße mit drin der Fisch an für sich
schmeckt super frisch manchmal finde ich
hat mir das Gefühl bei so okay und bei
so Paul Geschichten dass das Essen so
das ist ja vorbereitet und dann schon da
so ein bisschen liegt hier habe ich das
Gefühl dass es wirklich super frisch der
schmilzt im Mund wirklich mein für den
Preis point muss er auch recht muss er
wirklich das zu bewerten so in Zeiten
von Inflation was wissen wir was sie für
Standards an Ihren Einkauf haben die
Pferde ihre Mitarbeiter bezahlen wollen
was auch immer dazu führen kann das
Preise höher ausfallen deshalb ich sage
euch die Preise einfach dass sie aber
weitest gehen und kommentiert weil keine
Ahnung ich will niemanden der jetzt
gerade Unternehmer ist irgendwie Gastro
auf macht jetzt sagen ja euer Zeug ist
zu teuer weil die Qualität stimmt
unnormal schmeckt sehr sehr gut muss man
sich überlegen wie oft man sich das
bestellt wenn zu teuer ist klar ich habe
eine große Portion bestellt da ist aber
auch wirklich reichlich Thunfisch
überall ne auch unter dem Nori möchte
diese Basar wie Mario die ist in den
gesamten Reis eingearbeitet das macht
vielleicht ein bisschen weniger clean
als ich gehofft hatte ich glaube das ist
eine wichtige Aussage glaube ich die
beste Bau die ich gegessen habe bisher
aber das ist schon was so ich sage das
schmeckt richtig richtig gut
jo ich werde da glaube ich heute nicht
das letzte Mal bestellt haben auch wenn
es teuer ist und es hat wirklich gar
nichts mit Fitnessstudio zu tun hat
so geschmackvoll aber sei echt das ist
schon eine verdammt leckere wow heute
hat perfekt gezeigt warum es auch geiles
in der Großstadt zu leben Bro das waren
drei Kranke Spots in unter 30 Minuten
geliefert jedes einzelne teilweise unter
einer Viertelstunde geisteskrank das
war's jetzt auch von mir ihr habt wieder
gemerkt neue Dinge ausprobieren lohnt
sich ich habe drei Kranke Gerichte zu
mir nach Hause geliefert bekommen ich
hoffe das Video hat euch Spaß gemacht
bald geht's auch wieder in die Küche
haltet die Augen auf dem Channel wir
kochen immer eine Hälfte die andere
bestellen wird wir sehen uns beim
nächsten Video wieder bis dahin macht's
gut und ciao
nächstes mal auch mal die Empfehlung des
Hauses bestellen einfach mal
ausprobieren